after being postponed multiple times
finally the UN Security Council passed a
resolution calling for scaled up
humanitarian Aid into Gaza 13 votes in
favor Russia and the US abstained
allowing the resolution to pass without
a veto but at the behest of the United
States the resolution went through
several drafts throughout the week-long
delay behind closed doors the Americans
pushed to alter the wording of the
resolution to make it more fa favorable
to
Israel previous drafts called for an
immediate cessation of hostilities that
was later downgraded to suspension of
hostilities but even that language was
removed instead the final resolution
called to create the conditions for a
sustainable cessation of hostilities a
far cry from a ceasefire the previous
draft called for a un monitoring
mechanism to exclusively oversee Aid
ship shipments that was scaled back to a
senior coordinator appointed by the
Secretary General who will then
establish a monitoring mechanism but
that leaves the door open to possible
coordination with Israel and language
that explicitly condemned indiscriminate
attacks against civilians has been
altered to Simply call on all parties to
adhere to international law a frustrated
Russia tried to add back in language
calling for an iMed mediate cessation of
hostilities the US vetoed
it earlier I said the vote would be a
moment of truth and that's what happened
the US once again exposed their true
face in front of the world blocking an
even extremely weak call for a cessation
of hostilities in Gaza there's no
disconnect here we are all working to
address the humanitarian needs on the
ground and we're working to address
those needs immediately that's what the
this resolution is about Riad mansur the
Palestinian ambassador to the UN said a
full ceasefire is needed and there is
urgency to make it happen we will not
relent until we reach an immediate
ceasefire and having the massive amount
of humanitarian assistance to the
Palestinian people in the Gaza Strip as
for Israel it has ignored Security
Council resolutions in the past and
there are early indications that it is
prepared to do so again Israel's Deputy
un Ambassador said after the vote that
his country still reserves the right to
inspect all Aid going into Gaza as it
sees fit it's now up to the UN Secretary
General to figure out how to get more
Aid into Gaza as the resolution mandates
and he hinted that it could be quite
difficult unless Israel changes its
Behavior the real problem
is that the way Israel is conducting
this offensive is creating massive
obstacles to the distribution of
humanitarian Aid inside
Gaza an effective Aid operation in Gaza
requires security staff who can work in
safety logistical capacity and
resumption of commercial
activity these four elements do not
exist as difficult as the negotiations
were on this resol ution the real
challenge might be in the coming weeks
trying to implement it Gabriel zando Al
jaaz at the United Nations in New
York make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer